The next topic we'll start discussing is
Efficient Communication across address spaces. The client-server
paradigm is used in structuring system services
in a distributed system. If we're using
a file server in a local area network every day, we are using a
client-server system when we are accessing a
remote file server. And remote procedure call.
Is the mechanism that is used in building this
kind of a client server relationship in a distributed
system. What if the client and the server are
on the same machine? Would it also not be
a good way to structure the relationship between client
and servers using RPC. Even if the clients and
the servers happen to be on the same machine.
It seems logical to structure clients of a systems even
on the same machine using this RPC paradigm.
But the main concern is performance. And the relationship
between performance and safety. Now for reasons of safety,
which we have, talked a lot about when we
talked about operating system structures, you want to make
sure that servers. And clients are in different address
spaces, or different protection domains, as you've been calling
them. Even if they are on the same machine
uh,they will be running on different processors of an SMP,
but they're still on the same machine. You, what you want to
do is, you want to give a separate protection domain for
each one of these servers from the point of view of
safety. But, what that also means, because we are providing
safety, there's going to be a hit on performance. Because of the
fact that an RPC has to go across the outer spaces.
A client on a particular outer space, server on a different
outer space. So that is going to be
a performance penalty that you pay. Now as operating
system designers, what we would like to be able
to do. Is to make RPC calls across protection
domains as efficient as a normal procedure call
that is happening inside a given process. If you
could make the RPC across protection domains as efficient
as a a normal procedure call, it would actually
Encourage system designers to use RPC as a
vehicle, for structuring services, even within a same
machine. Why is that a good idea? Well,
what that means is that you know, we've talked
about the fact that in structuring operating systems
in microkernel, you want. You want to be able
to provide every service having its own protection
domain. What that means is that to go across
these protection domains, you're making a, a protected
procedure call or a RPC call. Going from
one from one protection domain to another protection
domain. And that is going to be more expensive
than. Simple procedure call. It won't encourage system
designers to use these separate protection domains to
provide the services independently. So, in some sense
again is the same question of wanting to have
the cake and eat it too. So you
want the protection and you also want the performance.